make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking back up again
with the Infinity ending and we're
actually we're ending the Infinity
ending I thought about titling that
infinity in being ending it seemed kind
of weird but in the last video we
basically left off with the idea that
Adam warlock was essentially met out of
nowhere by a person that I kind of left
you guys on a cliffhanger on and the
reality is it's not actually a person
but a group of people it's pretty much
all the versions of Adam warlock from
the past and the funny thing about this
is this goes all the way back to him
right the guy who's not wearing anything
but underwear that's how Adam warlock
first appeared when he was in Marvel
Comics and there's just different
iterations of his character as time has
gone on and the funny thing about this
is that Adam warlock has historically
been a guy where his understanding of
the the cosmos and the multiverse has
kind of been really beyond most other
people even the cosmic entities
themselves right it's the reason why
Thanos wanted him to become the new
living tribe you know we were reading
one of the older infinity stories but
when you when you get into this what you
end up having is the scenario where
these versions of Adam really kind of
say no like self-preservation is more
important than the universe and there's
a couple of reasons why they're coming
from this perspective the first is
because they're sentient beings right
it's just the nature of us as people we
care about ourselves more than we care
about other things right it's just the
way that we are and so what we also have
here is the notion that Adam warlock can
never truly die and so a matter no
matter what happens in this universe
where it ends or where it returns Adam
warlock will essentially always end up
returning and as other cells sort of
recognizes us right but the idea of Adam
warlock and this really kind of seems to
be an ideology force character this
changed over the years but the ideology
of item Adam warlock at this point in
time is saving the universe is the most
important thing and in reality it's not
as though they're killing off an entire
universe of people it's quite the
opposite defeat one guy in order to save
all of creation right is classic
utilitarianism the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few
and so is a cool perception here's a
cool notion here because Adam warlock
has been without his soul Jim for quite
some time now the reality is Adam
warlock doesn't really need the soul Jim
I mean it kind of helps to bolster his
power a bit but he never really needed
it I mean he was exceedingly powerful
even without the Jim but what he ends up
doing with these various guys he's
various versions of themselves is
basically snatching the soul Jim off of
one of their heads and then essentially
overpowering all the others now we don't
really know exactly what happens to them
but regardless of the situation the
result is that Adam warlock ends up
coming out on
and so following this he basically dives
through a portal and into the
consciousness of Thanos now this is not
the first time this has happened they've
been inside each other's minds before in
the subconscious mind of Adam warlock
it's all about death and rebirth right
people riding an elevator all the way up
to the top of this cliff more or less
falling off dying and then getting back
up and doing it all over again this
cycle of death and rebirth constantly
taking place with Thanos it was just
nihilism reign supreme right just just
death and destruction and so Adam kind
of dives into the mind of the one above
all Thanos that we're talking about now
and the funny thing about this is that
each one of these places that he sees is
now an entire universe unto itself Adam
warlock is hopping from one universe to
the next within the mind of one above
all phantos but that's more or less
what's going on here one of the first
memories he sees or one of the first
things he sees is stano's as a little
kid who basically breaks so a lamp now
the funny thing about this is we can
look at this a couple different ways
right we can look at this story as being
out of continuity or we can look at the
story being in continuity and the reason
why is because sui saans currently there
so those are the guys who read the rise
and fall of Tanis I think it was I think
was Ed Brubaker or Jason Aaron one of
those two who wrote it we basically got
the life and times of Thanos right all
the events that led to him in
encountering mistress death for the very
first time and then going forward and
becoming the villain that we that we all
know and love in the early days sweets
on land when I say early days I mean
like almost immediately after giving
birth mr ihsan tried to kill thanos
because she saw him as a bad omen
and had a vision that his actions would
lead to the downfall and the
destructions of everybody on titan which
it did and so she tried to take him out
and ultimately she was thrown in a
mental institution and so if this story
is in continuity at the time that Thanos
is this age Suisse on should be in a
mental institution but she's not she's
there so that kind of leads us to
believe that either it was jim Starlin
kind of trying to correct things and
saying no no this is how it should be or
it's not in continuity but the other
funny thing that kind of comes out of
this is eros and pip the troll now
remember these are two guys and while
they're not necessarily bumbling
buffoons they certainly don't have any
real kind of concrete plan right their
plan here to try to stop future Thanos
from acquiring all this insane power
capturing his modern-day self and then
going on to become the one above all
their whole attempt to basically stop
that is to convince Thanos that he's a
good guy that he's cool you know and
that like eros loves him and that's
basically it
right like words don't win conflicts
more or less and so because of that we
end up kind of jumping through these
different moments and fan OSes life and
you kind of have Dan
when he's relatively young when he's you
know kind of going through that that age
of bodies changing in puberty and he's
kind of put on a few pounds you know and
drinking a soda
it looks like and IRA's tries to
convince Stannis that like he's a cool
guy
you know the Thanos was great that etus
loves him and it is really eros like
trying to convince Thanos of this right
the next time they appear is when Thanos
is feeding some bullies to some monsters
in a cave because the bullies needed to
understand their place in the bigger
picture
following that like it's Bannos
basically launching an attack and
destroy the entire planet our planet of
Titan all these different things that
are going on with Thanos committing
these acts and as this is going on we
have two versions of Thanos here that's
one thing to keep in mind we've got
essentially what amounts to present-day
Thanos were the easiest way to think
about it and then we've got future
Thanos and if you guys recall in the
last video we talked about this right
future Thanos was the one that was
trying to attain the power to become the
one above all present-day Thanos is the
one who is being used in order to follow
in those footsteps and assure that that
path was actually followed and one
present-day Thanos went through all
those steps then he was absorbed by
future Thanos to ensure that nothing
would ever go wrong and that's why you
see this version of Thanos was sort of
hovering in a tank this is present-day
Thanos being held prisoner by his future
self and so ears and then basically
arriving to what's actually Thanos his
first appearance in Marvel Comics when
he fought Iron Man in terms of his a
chronological appearances we have them
showing up in instances like during the
events of Infinity Gauntlet these really
cool little moments here in there and
it's one of these things where
present-day Thanos kind of says okay
like I can reach you out basically
psychically and I can communicate with
them right I can talk to them through my
past self basically and that's what you
see playing out here right like eros and
his guys will show up to a particular
point in time and then Thanos will talk
to them and as they basically kind of
went over their plan but they only get
brief moments right they only get these
really really small moments and the
reason why this is kind of being held
off the reason why these moments are
only ever so short is because president
a fan OHS realizes that if they stop and
they talk for too long it'll create
abnormalities in the timestream that his
future version will become aware of and
then start tracing them down and
ultimately
realizing what it is at eros and pit
patrol are trying to do and at the end
of the day again it doesn't really
matter they're not actually doing
anything oh but it is kind of a cool
little effort right it is a cool attempt
one of the other funny things to come
out of this is that because of all these
paradoxes and all these shifts that eros
and hip Patrol are making they end up
showing up at a future point in time and
we have the cosmic entities but they're
different this
here actually does it really make any
sense and the reason why is if you
understand the nature of cosmic entities
the exists in two forms right they exist
in their true form which is an abstract
form it has no true physical form right
they're just an ideology if you had like
the desire to go get something to eat it
would be like if that desire to eat
could get up and walk around right that
thought that concept could get up and
move that's what a cosmic entity is now
when cosmic entities appear in a
physical form they go to the dimension
and manifestations and they basically
receive a form from anthropomorphic and
then they show up in the main Marvel
Universe in a physical form but it's
just what are these these these small
little things right so you know it's
it's a it's a cool little moment it's a
little a little wonky and a little crazy
but again that's kind of what we're
dealing with here or sort of these
escapades of jumping back and forth
through time and so when eros is talking
to present-day Thanos when they say like
like I guess we can work together and
eros is very much unsure about this
because it's trusting a guy who's well
known for betrayal Thanos is kind of
like at the end of the day our goals are
basically mutual here at the end of the
day like we're trying to achieve the
same goal
I'm currently trapped in the essence
more or less of my future self come
there rescue me and then like we'll save
the day and the cool thing about that is
that when that happens when arrow shows
up it's not really heroes saving Thanos
instead eros is seemingly kind of
whisked away
eros just sort of says like this isn't
right this isn't how it's supposed to be
and he just ends up taking off Adam
warlock pizzas head in to see what eros
is doing while he's on his journey and
then basically you know once once that
happens Adam warlock kind of pops back
in or at least sort of disappears for a
second when future Thanos shows up and
the reason why this matters is because
future Thanos as we know was looking for
eros not to kill him or to capture him
but because with eros existing outside
of life and death
dinner was basically impossible for one
above all Thanos to track him down now
again this is jim Starlin shifting
things around this is jim Starlin
changing things under normal
circumstances and everything up to this
point it's not how the one above all
work everything that is is the one above
all the face that you see when it speaks
to things is no different than eternity
copying up and then like talking to
somebody right it's just the entirety of
the omniverse on all things coalescing
in the form of a face that can have a
conversation with you with that being
the case anything even if it's outside
the realm of life and death is still
part of the one above all if it exists
if it talks if it's if it's anything
that can be drawn or written it exists
as part of the one above all so again
jim Starlin is kind of shift
things up and saying that's not
necessarily the case here right like you
know anything that exists outside of
life and death meaning it can't truly
die it's outside the one above all's
purview because it's considered an
anomaly right which is kind of crazy to
sort of limit the power of the one above
all and a lot of the guys are making
comments about that you were saying like
well I guess now he's just the one above
most is what it is and you're not wrong
right you're not entirely wrong the one
above pretty much most things unless the
plot calls for him to not be above
things like that's basically what it is
you know and so it's it's it's kind of
wild here but with IRA's having popped
up and basically shown up in the essence
of future Thanos to rescue present-day
Thanos by default he made himself part
of future Thanos therefore everything is
now complete my future Thanos has
attained his goal of tracking down eros
basically making eros a part of himself
even if it was only because eros just
sort of walked into it right so it's
essentially Thanos was trying to get us
into a house and eros just sort of
wandered in there on his own that's
really kind of what this is right now
when future Thanos basically leaves Adam
warlock then pops up and that's when
present-day Thanos is like you have to
free me from this prison where the the
responsive Adam warlock is no I'm not
going to do that you have to trust me
here you need to stay here this is all
part of my plan
now Thanos initially sort of questions
it and isn't really sure but the reality
is that Adam warlock is kind of a master
planner as one of these things where
when Adam warlock comes up with a plan
it's not really to be questioned the
issue it is is we're talking about
uncharted territory it's one thing to
create a plan just half Thanos lose the
Infinity Gauntlet because you get too
carried away with himself and because
warlock understands Fanus a subconscious
mind and how he thinks it's another to
form a plan against a seemingly nyama
'putin being that cannot truly be
destroyed by anybody here or really
anything in existence right so you know
like I have a plan to defeat of being
that cannot be defeated that's kind of
what that what that sort of comes down
to you and it's a little wild there
because what Adam warlock ends up doing
is basically watching all of this go
down right the idea was okay let's let
this play out and let's see what happens
it's a dangerous gambit because this
could fail in in the most spectacular
sense but future Thanos ends up doing
what he intended to do he ends up wiping
away all of reality now we didn't know
what the motivation was before but we
currently do now and the idea is that
future Thanos looks around and it's
almost kind of agreeable in terms of
what it is that he's doing and why he's
doing it right at the end of the day he
kind of makes his argument between
utilitarianism and deontology chol
ethics the intentions versus action
let's say for example that like you see
a homeless man and you give that
homeless man five bucks well your idea
is to just give that guy five bucks to
help him along his way but what if in
reality by giving him that $5 all you've
done is make him a target for somebody
else because he didn't earn that $5 he
doesn't know how to keep it and because
you don't know how to keep it either he
swindled by somebody who dupes him out
of it
or he's not physically capable of
holding it on his own somebody beats him
up and then takes it would he have died
had you not given him that $5 that's the
the philosophical quandary that we're
talking about here and depending on what
philosophical viewpoint you come from
whether you're at fault or not begins to
shift if we say the only thing that
matters is intention right that's the
only thing that really matters here is
intention then at the end of the day
it's like then your intention was to
make that guy's life better and that's
where your responsibility stops right
that's where it ends as far as you're
concerned you did what you thought was a
good thing done right we're finished
there from there then it starts going
into things like okay if all that
matters is action then you gave that guy
five dollars but then you also cost him
his life and so is your act more well
you know that's that's the kind of issue
that you run into here and so it's one
of these things where Thanos really kind
of looks at it and says the only thing
that really matters in this universe
matters in this world is actions right
what people's intentions are don't
matter what matters are deeds
and that everything is just a giant
contest right even the cosmic entities
seek to be supreme over the other in
some form or fashion despite the fact
that they're designed to be immutable
the despite the fact that they're
designed to be these forces that that
represent ideas and they don't really
seek to better one another at the end of
the day there's still a kind of contest
there and so Thanos his responses then
we'll recreate things loyalty was
conceived to deceive people
Trust is a fantasy for fools and is
basically played upon by scoundrels who
look to export the universe as it exists
now is one of naivety is people who
believe they can change the universe and
so on by just doing good things you're
believing good things but at the end of
the day like it's a screwed up and
terrible place this seems to be like the
core perspective of Thanos and so with
that being the case II says okay then
let's recreate everything and so with
that going down the you know without
happy in the way that it does you know
he basically goes to essentially
recreate all of existence and it offers
this momentary gambit right when you
have Adam warlock who's essentially
outside the existing multiverse washing
it all go down right once he retreats
outside of Thanos and kind of goes back
to this outside the multiverse kind of
space then in turn like once for
wipes everything out of existence and
then seems to recreate everything we
kind of get this brief moment where
present-day Thanos basically says okay
now's a chance to actually do something
I get this brief moment to basically
take this action and then basically Adam
warlock just kind of wakes up in the
void without any real indication of
where he is or where he's at he's just
kind of out in this total oblivion of
absolute nothingness and the indication
is that he's totally outside of all
recreated existence the omniverse as it
exists he's way out there to give you
perspective this is more or less just
stories that have not been told yet and
so with him being out there out in the
void out in the nothingness there's no
stars no planets no nothing just
infinite blackness but he ends up
getting this kind of lifeline that comes
through a sort of portal where he's
basically yanked forward by Kang the
Conqueror and that was the idea was to
really have Kang viciously grab eros and
pit patrol to ensure they stayed alive
Adam warlock didn't quite know what
would happen to him but the more
important thing was to ensure that
everything was safe and the plan
basically went as he expected that in
this moment of vulnerability in this
moment where future Thanos had basically
dispersed his energy or attempted to
disperses energy present-day Thanos
basically seized that power for himself
that after seizing all that power of the
one above all from his future
counterpart because of the fact that
present-day Thanos never really agreed
with his future counterpart his future
version ceased to exist
just by virtue of destroying his essence
more or less and then present-day Thanos
use the power of the one above all to
reset everything back to normal and this
is where the story totally falls short
and the reason why is because we don't
see any of that happen it's all
explained to Adam warlock by Kane the
Conqueror who watched it all go down
right so Adam warlock wasn't even really
a part of it he was on a part of seeing
everything recreated and all that kind
of stuff
some will probably say well we didn't
need to see that others will say
something something something jim
Starlin higher plane of reasoning who
knows but whatever the case is it's
basically one of these things were like
we missed out on what could have been a
really really cool appearance of a story
or some exposition and some explanation
there in terms of like why Thanos did
what he did in terms of like from his
perspective because we know why he did
what he did and we get the exposition
it's just from some time-traveling guy
that makes stories overly complicated
and so it's like okay that's kind of
weird and so they kind of make a final
stop it Adam warlock of course again
still in possession of the soul stone
presents the the reality stone to Thanos
and the truth and this is kind of the
important thing here the truth is that
it's entirely possible that his future
self could get carried away with power
again and the entire process
could repeat itself but it's one of
these things were Adam warlock trusts
Thanos right he trusts the character of
Thanos to do what needs to be done not
only that it basically we kind of have
this this sort of assumption that we
have to make that if present-day Thanos
did take the power of the one above all
from his future counterpart and then set
everything back that he may have just
kind of walked the timestream
just find out exactly what went wrong or
where he kind of lived through the
timestream so he knows the mistakes that
he made and we kind of have to assume
that like if he did set everything back
he's aware of himself he's aware of like
what he would what he will become or
something like that it's not clearly
explained it's not clearly defined and I
think that's kind of one of the issues
here it sort of leaves things pretty
ambiguous right and it really feels like
the ending in his story was wrapped up
super fast right he was just wrapped up
very very quickly and it sort of left a
bit to be desired but at the end of the
day things just kind of go back to the
way they were before light everything
just sort of goes back to normal and
then you kind of have Adam warlock who's
just sort of sitting there in a bar you
know out in it were really installing
bars where they call it Jim someone
named a bar after himself but he's just
kind of sitting in a bar and just sort
of chilling there and people kind of
have this concern that things are not
necessarily going back for the better
but at the end of the day we won't truly
know as far as I'm aware this is the
last of the infinity stories that jim
Starlin is right of course I think
infinity finale was also supposed to be
the last one and that it wasn't but at
the end of the day this is really where
it just kind of wraps up so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here too
comments explain and make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]